[Music]
hi everyone so welcome to sec - 102
around the cloud security command center
and also thank you for spending the last
part of your day with us we recognize
we're standing between you and drinks so
we'll hopefully keep this interesting
I'm Andy Chang I'm product manager
Google security team and also the
product manager for the cloud security
command center I'm joined here on stage
with both partners and customers and
song I turn over some of the other folks
I'm Michael Caputo I'm a cloud security
architect at 2 Sigma hi everyone
kamilla merrova solutions engineer and
special projects team at CloudFlare and
I'm Francesca Vega from Palo Alto
Networks I am a solution architect on
technical integrations and each of those
folks will be coming back on stage to
talk together Claire parts and so we're
gonna kick it off now so our goal today
is to really do four things talk to you
about how what an overview of the cloud
security command center is it's a
product we launched a public alpha back
in March and give you an update on where
we are with that also to provide
Michaels help an example of how 2 Sigma
is leveraging the cloud security command
center on their production systems and
then with two of our partners CloudFlare
and Palo Alto Networks how they're
integrating with cloud security command
center and providing additional
visibility into customers of signals
networking network traffic
Dawson wrap and then I'll summarize so
with the cloud security command center
our goal really is to provide that
canonical place in GCP for you to bring
all the things together that you care
about when you think about security risk
and privacy so it's really where we're
bringing together your assets from an
inventory standpoint the detections that
you have the findings the policies that
you're running the underlying
annotations that you want to put
specially on the resources bring that to
go so you have a unified view of that
weather
signals come from Google products from
third-party products from your own
detectors and our goal really is to kind
of give back to you visibility and
control so that you have the ability to
look at your attack surface so some of
the key things that from a functionality
standpoint the purpose of the cloud
security command center is really to
gather and integrate all that
information at an organization level so
you get to look across the different
projects and services as you're running
to allow you as we said to understand
and analyze that information to act on
that information and really to be a hub
for a range of Google security products
all in one place
and we recognize that we're not the only
player that you're going to have
especially if you're in a hybrid
situation so our goal and has been to
design this product and this platform is
API first so you can as well
egress and export this information to
your own systems to for further analysis
when we think about the general kind of
attacker defender kill chain and that we
see here the attacker kill chain
popularized by Lockheed Martin in 2011
at Google we also think about a defender
kill chain and from an offender's kill
chain side we think about two phases of
that being proactive in a pre fail mode
so you have an assessment of really what
your overall tax surfaces what you care
about what you should be focused on and
what matters to you to really be able to
specify ahead of time what are the
policies whether the configurations that
you want to run and also to be able to
then monitor the drift against those and
also to deploy protections things that
will by design enable you to kind of
prevent certain types of attacks and
vulnerabilities we also then think about
what happens in post fail right when
monitoring logging turned into detection
so the key signals that you find are the
ones that you're going to operate on
when you're investigating incident
obviously alerting on those things so
that your teams your instant response
teams can act on those and your saw can
act on those to be able to actually then
respond whether it's in a full fix or a
mitigation to they can be able to manage
your communications across those and
also very importantly to learn and
that's learn from a process standpoint
from people's band point as well from
machine
technology standpoint the cloud security
command center in the one is focused on
the first half of this chain being able
to enable you to do a much better job of
proactive protection by giving you the
visibility and those assets in those
findings we think about how this plays
in context this is a framework that we
look at when we think about helping our
customers become more secure so at a
high level we think about the risks that
you're looking at really in five
categories they're really securing the
underlying inventory and that's the
inventory of hardware and software
you're running in your systems securing
the data that's data that either you've
created or data that you've captured
from your end customers securing the
configurations so that each of the
services you start off in is in a
best-practice known good state and
understanding the drift against that
securing your Identity and Access design
management design so that you have the
proper amount of access and control to
the different permissions and policies
and then helping you secure the
applications that you build on our own
infrastructure so matching that or the
capabilities we're building into the
cloud security command center which will
demo in a few minutes
first is the acid inventory to give you
that view of both the current state and
historical state of assets the ability
to track when my assets have changed and
how they've been modified and to really
manage those assets and group them in
business relevant ways beyond just
what's in the resource hierarchy in
addition one of the core things and what
we exciting to hear from both to sigmah
CloudFlare and Palo Alto is bringing in
signals in to the findings that matter
to customers in one place so they can
make decisions on that and then the
ability really to provide you as a
customer the ability to create filters
and queries to find the specific data
that you want obviously the visibility
side is one part and then the action
part is the other so the ability to mark
things so that you can group them by
priority the ability to create
notifications through a sidecar
application that we ship with the
product the ability as well to do
mitigation remediations again through a
sidecar connection to cloud functions
and then finally to be that hub for the
security products like our nomally
detector
our web security scanner and our DOP
technology so what you'll see in the
demo forthcoming is really the UI part
of the command center that you I really
has three main surfaces the first is the
dashboard which is really the overall
view of what's going on on in your
system and give you ability understand
and look at what's hot what's happening
what you should focus on and then where
we see analyst and security
professionals spend most their time is
in the inventories we have an asset
inventory so that you can take an asset
centric view of what's going on your
system as well as a findings inventory
that you can take a finding centric view
and they both cross leverage each other
and then finally for any entity that
we've indexed whether it's an asset or
resource or a finding we have the
ability to drill in at a detail level so
you can look like the underlying
properties so without further ado I'm
gonna switch over to the demo so what
you're seeing here now is live version
the cloud security command center it
basically is in an organization that
we've created that organization has a
bunch of assets routes sub networks
firewalls buckets instances disks you
can look at it historically so we can
see what changed seven days ago so over
the last seven days we've added a bunch
of routes we've deleted one of the
unknown things we've looked at the
firewalls we've got to look at the
overall disappea PSA's if we go back say
three months you'll see that the system
has even have changed more radically
over that period of time and this gives
you kind of an ongoing record time
series of what you how your asset state
is in addition we have the finding side
of the world which is looking at the
various signals that are integrated in
to tell you what we've collected around
either good bad findings for each of the
underlying assets so first is an unreal
overall finding summary card which takes
a look at what are the different
detectors and what have they surfaced
and then we start with three of the
Google detectors so we have a cloud
anomaly detector that allows you on a VM
basis to understand when we think
there's account hijacking going on when
there's potentially coin mining
data exfiltration potentially if your
vm's been compromised and being used in
a das net if your VM has been
compromised its being used to try to
intrude on other systems in addition we
have our web security scanner which is
available in GA and App Engine and is in
public alpha for GCE
and gke and that lets you find things
like cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities outdated libraries mixed
content you can run that on your
publicly facing applications and those
results automatically surface in command
center when there are findings in
addition we're integrated with the DLP
technology that we announced I think a
year of more than a year ago it next
which allows you to scan all of your
public buckets and scan all your buckets
in your system and then classifies
whether there is PII found in those
buckets and that gives you a sense of
the surface area and the blast radius of
when things potentially are compromised
where your data is what data is highly
sensitive in addition we're integrated
with for SETI so for SETI is Google's
open source effort to build a security
community around GCP and has a set of
scanners that both Google has
contributed as well as our partners and
community members and for SETI have
contributed which of those results also
index and can be surfaced in command
center and then we have a range of
partner integrations from the container
security side CloudFlare which Camilla
will talk about more detail
folks like CrowdStrike dome 9 palo alto
networks which francesco will talk about
in more detail Qualis red lock Cystic
stack rocks and twist lock so that gives
you a sense of and this would obviously
be a really unhappy system for all these
bad things were happening to it so as I
said this is that place where customers
go on a daily basis to see what's going
on and then if they want to go
investigate they would dig into
something like the acid inventory so the
structure of the acid inventory is one
that first you can slice your data based
on either the projects or the underlying
assets and as we we cover App Engine GCE
gke
GCR docker images and then GCS from a
bucket standpoint currently and then
will be continuously adding more of the
Google services you can take that view
of either for example I want to look at
all my buckets you can just truncate on
that or instead if I wanted to go to a
particular project and let's say I want
to go to this dev project and then I
wanted to look at just all the buckets
that are in that so I would basically
select attribute asset type type buckets
and then this filters down to just the
buckets within that project so the way
we've constructed this is what you
select on the left and the kind of
overall resource hierarchy on the right
you get only the assets that belong that
resource hierarchy and you can further
filter things so one of the things that
we can look for which people care about
is you know what if I expose one of my
buckets publicly how would I find that
so first I would look again I go across
my organization I'd wanted to go ahead
and search again for my buckets and then
once I've searched for my buckets I'd
want to look at one of the properties
and that would be the Akal property and
say let's say if I have in all
authenticated users on that and sure
enough we have one bucket we've exposed
to public right so what does that mean
we can dig into that a little bit more
that bucket basically has a set of
attributes set of detailed properties
specific to it you can see right here
that the authenticated users has been
set up as a reader so if that's intended
that's great but if that's a bucket with
highly sensitive information that would
be bad and you want to remediate that
the other thing that we want to cover a
little bit is from a time standpoint so
if we go back to this demo this changed
on add about let's see last scanned at
3:58 so if we were to look back at
yesterday and we can go back to
yesterday we can figure out whether this
bucket was actually public yesterday or
not
so as of yesterday it wasn't so it
happened sometime between now and then
and we can look at then
to figure out what that occurred in
addition from an asset inventory side we
can also slice things based on the
findings so from the findings first you
see you have again two choices you can
see things either listed by all the
possible findings or you can sort them
by the particular source type and so we
have findings from each of the
underlying sources if we were to dig
into a flying let's say our own anomaly
detector we could find and dig into the
VM that has coin mining and what that
ends up telling again on our detail page
is what actions should be taken against
that what it's against it's an active
finding and underlying summary of what's
going on for third parties like
CloudFlare or palo alto when we have an
integration there they surface their
findings as a summary just like any
other finding you can drill into that
finding
they provide underlying detail and then
you can connect back to the partner
console so go back into the CloudFlare
system in this example look at the
particular website that's involved and
then dig into the underlying data there
as well so that's the kind of
integrations that we have with the
underlying providers so to wrap up this
part of the demo you know what we've
covered today really is some of the
underlying capabilities for filtering
and searching one last thing we have the
ability to do is for you to create marks
and what those marks allow you to do is
to group data by things that matter so
for example I create a mark previously
around an incident and I care about all
the different findings that are relative
that incident so I've already pre marked
them so that becomes these eight or nine
findings and similarly on the asset side
I've also put that mark together on some
of the assets that are relevant to this
and so as we go ahead and then put the
same incident number in at pre-filters
down to those and then I can go in the
dashboard and again look and see just
for the assets that are relevant to that
incident as well as the findings the
relevant that instant so with this I'm
going to switch back to the slides and
so what we covered there was the asset
inventory the findings the ability to
filter and search and the ability to use
the marks and also the integrations with
a range of our partners
what we now want to talk about is you
know as one of the core parts and the
differentiation for command center is
the ability integrate all those findings
so we're going to dig a little bit
deeper and then what that means
what findings are what finding sources
are so for us we've defined findings
very broadly they really are an output
from a source and it could be a curated
output it could be a raw output that
then applies to an asset that we've
indexed or resource of the weave index
and that allows us to build that
connection to do either a finding
centric view of the world or an asset
centric view of the world and it's valid
for a particular time or between two
time points so that allows us to tie
that into its history and its life cycle
and they need to have a unique ID
because we automatically dedupe findings
within command centers so if you have
the same finding 6 or 7 times it doesn't
show up as 6 or 7 findings it shows up
as the same finding and it just updates
its properties and its timestamp as it
goes and so that allows things to be
correctly indexed and joined in the
command center database when we think
about findings they come from finding
sources in our mental models so far for
finding sources is really around the
ability to think of three main types
scanners which really provide you at
essentially a snapshot in time of the
state of your whole system or the state
between two time points and what that
allows us to do is to say that
represents the kind of complete state
that we want to integrate in and see
what's going on for that time
examples of scanners are the cloud
security scanner that we've integrated
within Google the DLP scanner as well
they both scan the state of either an
application or a set of buckets at a
point in time the standard l3 l4 network
scanners that are scanning ports because
again if they have a overall scan across
a set of ports they have underlying
results things from the container image
scanners from folks like twistlock and
the second type of finding source that
we integrate with our monitors and so
those are things that grease event
streams so the common example of that
are agents that are put into either VMs
or into containers and they prevent
basically a stream of events with no
history back to the system and the third
type of source that we integrate with
our really loggers so that's the
canonical log file ingestion where
that's a series and historical record of
a series of events they can ingest it
and processed so if you as a customer or
you as a partner have one or more of
these types these are types that we can
integrate in and have their results join
together with the rest of the findings
in this cloud security command center I
think a little bit more about how that
happens what we show here is a
screenshot of our Alpha API it's a
little hard to read there's a link
directly to our documentation which is
it's a public documentation of how you
use the create findings API the key
thing is that there are really seven
things that you need to provide as
someone who wants to write results to
our command center the first as we
talked about is that unique ID so that
we can do our own deduping the second is
the actual insight that you want to
surface in command center both in the
dashboard and as kind of the key title
in indexing for the findings inventory
the third thing is the mapping to the
one or more Google Cloud assets that
these findings apply to and the fourth
thing is a timestamp so as we're
historical record we're able to put that
finding in place relative to other
things in our time database and then
lastly the link back to if you're a
commercial vendor your own portal
because our goal in our philosophy with
integration is to really surface the key
things that we think are relevant to the
customer if they want to go in deep and
dive in more detail we fully expect that
they'd want to go into your own
dashboard and explore those using the
tools that you've invested in so that
linkage as we showed with the cloud for
example provides that two-way kind of
transition and then lastly the key thing
to add is the finding specific
properties so when you surface a
fighting in your side as either a
customer or as a partner identifying the
key items that you want the end customer
to see that will drive them to an action
that will help them get to a more secure
space what partners get from integrating
with the Cloud Security command center
and what they gain are really showing up
in four key places first in the summary
on the dashboard as we saw with each of
the dashboard cards second in the
inventories both actually in the
findings inventory and in the acid
inventory because the assets can index
into the findings into the specific
detail pages which allow the customer to
drive action and then actually into our
data cube index which is our back-end
database which allows you to search
select and find the API and the views if
we think about integration there's
really three options if you are a
customer or a partner of how you can
integrate data into the cloud security
command so the first option assumes that
you have a presence in GCP itself and so
you know in this model as a customer the
customer has an organization GCP you
have an organization in GCP the first
step is for you to essentially scan the
customers instance or instances or
organizations so that you find out
what's going on the second is to spin up
a connector project in your own
organization which will end up being the
intermediary between your overall
back-end and our cloud security command
center the third is to do than the
authorization so that your service
account for your project is authorized
to write a security command center for
the customers as well as you do your own
authorization to your own back-end to
uniquely identify the customers
information
that you want to send and then to push
the data from your back-end into the
cloud security command center via that
connector project the second option is
if you're not running on GCP at all is
to instantiate your connector product
project and after you do the scanning in
the customers organization so to provide
the basic underlying code it allows the
customers stand up that connection point
again authorization both towards us and
the cost customers cloud security
command center as well as do your own
back-end so the right data gets to the
right place
and then connecting the data through and
through and the third option is if you
not running anything on GCP and you have
completely partner back-end is again to
first scan the customers information and
our organization for the results that
you want to run and then through the
customer authenticate allow them to
authenticate into your system provide an
h2 API key that gives them access to the
command center
and once that API key is installed on
your back-end you can then write to the
security command center specific to that
organization so those are three methods
we've had customers and partners use
each of these three methods to do
integration and if you want to find out
more information please find me after
the talk so to summarize the kind of
first part of the cloud security man
Center is at the end of the day the goal
is to integrate in one place and unify
our assets resources and findings if you
want to integrate your findings in the
command center our kind of partner model
is really set up in three stages first a
scenario definition between the product
managers so that collectively we're
looking at the end customers journey so
the right set of data gets surfaced and
command center and the right pull and
kind of pull through occurs to drive
them back to your own console
prototyping so that we build an example
first within a demo organization that us
and the partner managed and then find a
lead customer to kind of go deploy that
live with and then finally the execution
and deployment at scale for general
availability for
customers so with that I've kind of
given you an overview of both the
capabilities of cloud command center as
well as how partners integrate with
command center what I'd like to do now
is to turn this over to Michael Capp
kado from two sigma talk to you a little
bit about how they've used cloud
security command center so my name is
Michael Cal picado I'm a cloud security
architect at SU Sigma and I kind of
wanted to introduce like who 2 Sigma is
what we do and a little bit about how we
approach cloud security before I show
you what we're doing with the security
command center so 2 Sigma is a New York
city-based hedge fund we use things like
artificial intelligence machine learning
distributed computing all kind of the
latest technologies to drive our
investment strategy and for that reason
you know operating in the public cloud
has been extremely important to us so
that we can scale scale up and scale
down very dynamically to give you an
example we use something like 35
petabytes of data to build our
investment models and this is you know a
growing number and so like one of the
primary concerns we have in cloud
security is really protecting against
data exfiltration so all of the code and
data that we write and generate it's
very important for us to protect protect
against this leaking right that's our
job so that's the approach we take and
we really think about it in three ways
right we use defense in depth so that we
have a layered approach to security if
we kind of make a mistake in one area we
can fall back on other areas we use
automation very heavily right as the
public cloud has moved
I guess as we've moved into the public
cloud we've seen things scale up a lot
quicker right people can procure VMs in
a few seconds as opposed to like a few
months and so obviously the attack
surface scales very quickly and this
means that we have to react quickly so
we use automation from a security
perspective for things like secure
approval and deployment pipelines very
repeatable security processes and then
of course there is like the continuous
audit piece and that's extremely
important to us because even though you
set up your environment in a secure
manner on day one six months later or
two years later it's
drift right the configuration and the
environment is going to change and so
you want to have some sort of system
that's continuously auditing your
environment to kind of have control over
what's going on and to react to any
changes so just to talk a little bit
more about defense-in-depth if you think
all the way up at a very high level you
have like your organisation in GP GCP
and you can apply something like an
organization policy what this does just
to give you an example is it it it's
really like a blanket security control
on your whole org so one example of how
we use that is we build like a secure
image say a secure Debian image with all
of the security controls and OS
hardening kind of mechanisms that we use
and then we apply an org policy that
says in any of the folders or projects
that to Sigma has we want users to only
be spinning up VMs from that secure
image right so that's kind of all the
way at the top of the stack bubbling
down a little bit into the individual
folders and projects we create custom
iam roles for our users and groups and
we do this based on a least permissive
model right so only the kind of minimum
set of permissions those users need to
operate successfully in their
environment we create a custom role and
assign it to them things like VPC
security controls to kind of draw a
secure boundary around all of our
resources and then all the way down to
the individual resource level so if you
think about like bigquery datasets you
can have access control lists on those
actual data sets another example is a
GCS bucket which I'm going to be using
in the demo so those both have concept
of access control lists and you can
control the security at the individual
resource level right and then speaking a
little bit more about the automation we
use there's some I guess unexpected
consequences of using certain GCP API so
to give you an example of that
if you authorize your users to create a
data set in bigquery when they create
that data set they actually become the
owner on the data set access control
list and the consequence of that is they
can turn around and share that data set
even with users outside your
organization right so for us this is
like a huge shock because
we're trying to prevent data leakage and
obviously we can't have like sensitive
data loaded into a data set and then
just the any user can share that with
the world
so an example of how we use automation
to fix that is we've actually written a
server list cloud function that creates
data sets on behalf of users and so they
call that cloud function the cloud
function creates the data set and it
strips all of the owners out of vehicle
kind of fixes it up and then it returns
back to the user you know here's your
new data set you can use it at this link
and really the last piece is you know
even though we've taken an approach that
uses defense-in-depth that uses
automation that's really kind of the day
one set up of the environment and it
drifts over time so we use in
conjunction cloud security command
center and for SETI really to monitor
our environment to audit and ensure that
those security guard rails are still in
place and then to surface any violations
of that to us so I'm just curious show
of hands how many people are familiar
with ferzetti
awesome cool okay so two Sigma's are
contributor to first SETI and like I
encourage you guys to become
contributors if you're interested that
working with the cloud security command
center and for study teams has been
extremely positive they've been like
super helpful and we've been able to to
contribute some coats of fur SETI and to
get that merge into the latest branch so
I'll talk a little bit about that later
but for those of you who haven't used
for SETI or heard of your study it's
really a tool that lets you scan your
environment and you can write very
simple rule sets in Yama format for any
as an example if we keep using this
bigquery example you could write a rule
that says I don't want any at two Sigma
comm users in my dataset I call ever and
and for study we'll run periodically it
will scan through all of your datasets
and it will find violations of that rule
and you can surface those in various
ways you can you know get an email to
yourself I know they're building out
integration with pub/sub and slack but
of course we use cloud security command
center is kind of our central pane of
glass and so we wanted to surface
commands into there and that's possible
today with first study there's
integration between the two
so let me walk you through a little bit
of an example this is kind of what I'm
in a demo but I just wanted to show you
guys what happens first right so it's
very similar to the bigquery example so
let's say you have a user Bob he joins
your company and he wants to create a
bucket so he's going to install the
Google command-line utility and he's
gonna make a simple API call to create
that bucket and the unintended
consequence of this is in the backend
the data set has a access control list
and Bob just became owner on that bucket
and he can now share it right and if
you're trying to protect buckets and
make sure that they don't get shared
outside of your organization this is
kind of an undesirable effect right so a
bucket owner equals Bob owners can share
I kind of already explained that this
opens up a very easy path for data
leakage so what we would do I guess if
we were thinking about things from a
very manual perspective as a diligent
security team we would want to go modify
the Akal on that bucket right and of
course there's like a an API call to do
that so we could install the
command-line utility and say I want to
change the aqwal on the bucket and I
want to set Bob to be an editor and not
an owner but you can imagine that as
your organization scales and there's you
know hundreds or thousands or tens of
thousands of users all creating buckets
you're not going to hire a hundred
people on your security team to
constantly go change the Akal on all of
the buckets right so what you would
probably do in that scenario is you
would abstract it away
with a cloud function or something like
that like I explained before but that's
kind of only the initial set up that
means that when the bucket gets created
you're gonna remove unintended owners
from the Akal it doesn't mean that it's
gonna stay that way forever right and
there's always going to be like super
users in your organization that can go
and make changes whether maliciously or
just by mistake
so this is where cloud security command
center really helps us Andy talked a
little bit about the security marks that
you can apply so we use these in a bit
of a different way we mark resources in
security command center with a security
level right so it could be like open in
Journal restricted super super
restricted and what we do is we use
these marks to differentiate resources
and we can apply scanning to only
certain classes of resources that we
care about so let's like just walk
through that right what we would do
rather than creating buckets on behalf
of the users is we would create that
security mark and in this case we're
just saying the buckets that we care
about are restricted they have a
security level of restricted and now
let's say that someone makes a mistake
and they add Alice as like an owner on
that bucket Akal we have some very
simple code that we run on a periodic
basis and you could run this in a cloud
function you could run this in App
Engine you could just run this on a VM
if you're not familiar with those
services and what that code does is it
will go reach out to cloud security
command center and we'll say give me a
list of all of my resources all of my
assets that are security level
restricted and if any of them have kind
of unintended changes like say the
bucket Akal has been changed in the past
10 minutes or 24 hours create a finding
create a finding on that asset and
security command center so that the
incident response team can go and take a
look at that and kind of fix it so I'll
show you a simple demo now we'll switch
over to the demo awesome so I've got
this bucket here called next 18 demo and
you can see on the can everyone see that
or should i zoom in zoom in a little bit
right so it's got a security level of
restricted if I just dive into it you'll
see here it's it's marked as restricted
and right now there's 14 findings now I
want to point out we hope to see more
findings if the demo is successful those
14 are for me testing it so that I could
make sure it worked for you all so right
so we've got that bucket it's got 14
findings right now and the thing we care
about is whether or not the Akal has
changed in whatever time period we've
defined so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go over to the actual bucket
here and in the console you can actually
edit the permissions of the bucket and
this is how the access control lists on
the bucket gets
controlled so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to add myself and I'm just gonna
pick something random like say storage
legacy bucket owner awesome so you can
see I've added myself to the bucket ah
cool so the aqwal should have changed
now and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to just rescan all of our assets
in cloud security command center this
should take about a minute or two so
while this is running I'm just gonna
walk you guys through the code a little
bit of the code and today we're running
this on like an hourly basis but we
could speed this up if we wanted to and
I guess it's worth pointing out that you
know initially cloud security command
center only had like a REST API exposed
but now there's a Python client library
so for those of you who are like
familiar with Python it's very simple to
interact with security command center
and write great some simple code that
interacts with it basically right so
I've got this method here called check
changes and this is very simple all its
going to do is it's going to take a
start time of 15 minutes ago
and an end time of now and it's gonna
say in that 15-minute window get all of
the assets from security command center
that have a security level of restricted
mark on them and if any of them have
changes that we care about create a
finding right so there's a another
method called find changes and this
makes a call-outs of security command
center get assets by mark so it's one of
the API methods you can use you can
retrieve all of the assets from security
command center that have a certain mark
and of course for different assets
you're gonna care about different things
right for a bucket we care about the
Akal and the owners on the bucket but
for something like an instance or a
firewall you might care about different
properties so we just have a simple if
statement here that says for all of the
assets that come back sort them by type
and if it's a bucket in this case it's
the only one we're checking in this step
we go into this method here bucket
changes and so what we then do is we
make another call to cloud security
command center and we get the final
asset so we have the asset
representation at the beginning of the
15-minute window and then at the end of
the 15-minute window and we compare
those two so here here's the one we're
kind of interested and we say if the
initial assets Akal is different than
the final asset cycle then just call out
to security command center and create a
finding that says the bucket ichael has
changed and I'll show you how simple it
is to actually create that finding so
this is that was all like kind of my
custom logic code and stuff this method
here which was probably about five lines
of code is creating a finding in cloud
security command center so that's really
all you need right we generate a unique
ID for the finding we specify the
category we specify the source and an
arbitrary JSON blob of properties and
then just the asset that we want to
create the finding on so in this case
it's a bucket so I'll actually run the
demo now we'll hope it works so it scan
through a bunch of buckets and you can
see they're for the for study or for the
next 18 demo bucket which is the one
that I just changed it found two things
and it sent them to cloud SCC so if we
go back to the console now and I'll just
update this to now we should see not
just 14 there right so we can see now
there are 16 findings right so the
default object Akal and the bucket
alcohol both changed this was like 5 15
just a couple of minutes ago and yeah
that's really it so what we do is we
basically run this code and we've
extended it since then to look at
different things not just buckets and
their apples and we run this just on a
VM today and it wakes up every so often
runs surfaces findings to us and then we
react to them basically so we'll flip
back to the slides awesome
so I wanted to talk just a little bit
before I get offstage about cloud
security command center and for study in
the integration between the two so when
we first got exposed to these two
services the way it worked is for study
would basically construct a list of
violations that it found based on all
the rules that we had written and it
would push these to a GCSE bucket and
then cloud security command center would
reach out to that GCSE bucket it would
parse all of the violations and it would
load them into findings we thought this
was like a little bit clunky it was the
only thing available at the time but
then you know one day Andy and I were
talking and the API for cloud security
command center had been exposed and so
we thought why not make this a little
bit better so what we did is we worked
kind of closely with the first study and
the cloud security command center teams
and we modified that code so that we use
the security command center API directly
so for any of you who are using for
study today you'll be familiar with like
a Yama file that you configure for study
with you tell it like what notifiers you
want to run what rules you want to run
in the scanner there's a new section and
where you enabled the Cloud Security
command center integration before you
can now say either use the bucket mode
or the API mode and if you set it to API
mode it's going to use the API directly
rather than using that GCS method of
writing to a bucket and there was really
like a couple reasons why we wanted to
do this one was obviously it's just
cleaner to use the API directly and not
have to rely on that like latency of
writing something to GCS and then
waiting for it to be read but the other
reason is we have a lot more control now
within the first setting codebase to
publish whatever properties we want
directly into that finding in cloud
security command center so based on the
rules that you're that your scanner is
using you can write different property
fields into cloud security command
center all right so that's it for me I
have a wrapping up slide here not much
for me to talk about but really I just
wanted to link to the github code base
there so you could see kind of the
integration between the two services and
I encourage you guys to play around with
it so thank you and I'll invite Camilla
from CloudFlare up now
[Applause]
hello everyone I hope everybody can hear
me well just give me a second
all right so those of you who haven't
heard about CloudFlare which is not a
big surprise
we probably one of the largest internet
companies you might maybe not aware of
but you have used us today everyone in
this room would have gone to one of our
millions websites properties api's
applications that actually been
protected and accelerated by CloudFlare
in fact every single person which uses
internet today
touches our network every week our
mission is to build a better internet so
where are we today you can see it on the
slides that we build a massive network
we have over 150 data centers globally
and the number is going more points of
presence means that we create less
latency for websites and applications an
AP has to be reached but it also helped
us to mitigate really large attacks DDoS
attacks we handle about 10% of the
global HTTP traffic and our network
capacity about 15 terabytes per second
currently we actually have about 8
million applications websites and api's
that use us well this has slide is helps
you to understand where CloudFlare
stands with Google cloud we're not just
the partners Google also our Investor as
CloudFlare we refer to ourselves as edge
network provider so those of you know or
what is actually edge edge is where you
meet the business in the internet or in
the internet originally if you might
remember there was a once you open your
web browser or application on your phone
you connected directly to the service
which is actually used for that business
but we become extremely extremely
demanding in terms of performance
reliability and of course security we
expect walking down on the street having
our phone with us order a taxi and
almost immediately see where is it on
the map location we expect looking down
on the street and FaceTime our parents
or families in a high definition and
being actually everywhere on the globe
so in order to achieve this a new layer
have been introduced in the Internet
this is what is called edge and this is
where you are connecting to business
today and this is where CloudFlare sits
speaking about the security aspect and
be efficient in it many companies facing
the following challenges let's take for
example real use case of a customer
which is one of our customers online
video platform with running classes on
internet around the globe they have an
infrastructure with using multiple
clouds and also something on premise
like imagine to maintain and manage the
whole security policy and security
aspects for all that heavy sophisticated
environment the challenges first of all
is that it's all different tools to use
all the different interfaces the way too
many way how you can get that
information but you have to know each
tool separately to evaluate this
information by itself or run a special
script to get that information gathered
in one place so we can finally analysis
it or another case in our case for
example our customers they see
information that happening on their data
centers on the server which isn't
running on for example Google cloud
platform but also what's happening on
the edge but they don't have an option
where to see that things together this
is where Google Cloud common security
Center plays actually a very powerful
role it
is a sinful interface where you are able
within the same unified dashboard to see
that data that coming also from the edge
and as well as from your actually
servers that is running on CloudFlare
bended integrate built an integration
with cloud security common center to
extend actually security from data
center all the way to the edge and cloud
for dashboard actually Google Cloud
common security dashboard as you can see
it here being populated with a firewall
web brocation firewall and IP firewall
events that actually running in a
real-time that help you to understand
what's happening right now on the edge
with your services so let's talk take a
look a little bit of the solution in
more details and how actually works with
the integration itself the first step
we're going through the Google cloud
platform you think yeah with a simple
click of a button the customer like to
Sigma or any other customer creates an
instance of app engine and while it's
created it also generates a unique
public key URL there will be used on
cloud website to encrypt the data to
send them to Google cloud platform App
Engine API so an all communication is
happening over SSL so let's move on
cloud website to see what's happening on
our edge these keys in cloud flow UI
customer uses JavaScript which is run
within the edge workers so now you ask
me what is actually edge workers so
while we maintaining security a
performance aspects for our customers
CloudFlare introduced an additional
functionality CloudFlare edge workers
which allows you to run the code on the
edge instead of your server so which
immediately reveals a powerful
functionality and web extensibility by
moving your logic from the server all
the way to the edge which means you can
run a be testing now you can decide
which traffic you want to face it and
tested it and load-balancing it also
improving user experience that
everything now can run on the edge
instead of like creating that latency to
get the compute and calculations on your
server and goes back and again so that's
a huge huge huge advantage so in this
current integration you can see this
edge worker acts like a proxy actually a
very powerful proxy what it does it
actually connected while API to
CloudFlare API to download the logs
which is actually gathered from all our
150 data centers and send it back to
edge worker where each worker encrypts
his data with public key that we got
generated in App Engine instance and
send it to Google cloud platform where
App Engine instance get this data and
post it through cloud SCC API to cloud
common security Center dashboard so it
run quite fast and also very important
that on top of all that functionality we
very care about security point and this
is very very important to both systems
they won't expose their sensitive data
so private API key that used by edge
workers to download the data from cloud
free edges remains within the system as
well as Google Cloud Data as well on top
of that we have improved security by
allowing to lock requests coming to
CloudFlare edge only from Google a sin
number or you can also set up a rate
limiting so that you know
that it has that extra security levels
all right now let's with answering dive
into demo if you could switch the demo
please alright so I prepared the small
example here it's the website is called
usual website calm in this case we're
gonna run it on a real use case let's
say I'm an e-commerce site actually
selling Argentinean wines actually a lot
more back so no secrets and I want to
make sure that I'm protected and I
benefiting from performance and also
able to see everything that happening
both on data center and the edge from
security standpoint so let's switch to
the Google cloud interface and this is
where my website is a simple WordPress
site that is actually being built on App
Engine
that's running on the demo target
project that's way it's actually has
been serving and as a separate project
and the security center API project I
actually made an installation of App
Engine that talks to CloudFlare edge
workers so now I'm going to switch to
CloudFlare UI to get you understand what
is happening here in call so UI as well
as you managing all your DNS security
performance settings you also have here
workers section so I'm going to launch
an editor the way a CloudFlare workers
work it's using actually different Java
scripts so that's the JavaScript that
adapted for your needs and using your
own credentials you can see it here the
if you might recall a public URL that
can be encrypted that's the one that can
be used by the worker and all you need
is just a peter button safe because it's
already have that information filled out
you can see it here already
API key and every cinch is stored within
this edge workers with never leaves
CloudFlare edge so once we push the data
it's actually ends up in security common
Center and I'm gonna know a little bit
to make it small so that you can see
what's actually happening within the
dashboard as other companies we have a
cloud fair card where you can see let's
say a quick glance of statistics that's
actually happening on your edge you can
see the top trend origins there the
percentage of them as well and you can
see the type of tress we've been seen
like a firewall IP rate limiting and
what the last scene events in the couple
let's say if it's a minutes or hours
something that hit our edge so if you
want to look at the each of them in
details we'll just click on the card or
we just click on the findings and on the
CloudFlare which you have a list of
events that being captured and populated
here so let's have a look at one of that
in this event what it can tell us it can
tell us that it's actually IP rate
limiting exceeded
you can see actually the asset ID which
one going to be used in this case and
scanner ID which is CloudFlare in this
case when it happened and the timestamp
very important that's something that is
very allows you Income Security Center
go back in time so you can look at you
can filter it upon that request or
events that you are interested in it
also helps you to identify which VM or
which App Engine or
container is actually happening on right
now so let me find another very quick
event that I can give you idea of what
extra information you can see it here
just gonna do it here yeah for example
sickle problem yep in this it shows you
the organization it shows you the
information about what the request
method it was what the host name the
country and other external informations
so if you want to make any changes
you still need to log in through the
partner link to cloud fly UI and let's
say block this IP about the country or
challenge it very easily
alright that's actually all for the demo
and I'm gonna hand over the talk to
Francesco from Palo Alto Networks
I'm actually starting with the demo it's
not really the demo but I just got an
email from a friend and I wanted to
start can you switch to demo - yeah so I
got that this email about the superfast
Bitcoin miner which sounds interesting
right so I want to actually start mining
right now on this cloud machine so I can
get rich maybe I can pay for some drinks
later on so let me download this one
copy on the desktop this is the machine
running in the cloud I will see I mean
let me try that I think it's a good idea
right - to do this on the cloud right so
let's do it okay it's been blocked by
traps our endpoint protection so it
wasn't really a good idea fortunately
nobody's watching right nobody's
recording right my boss is nothing in
the room oh he is okay forget about that
let's switch to the slides for a second
so how many of you know Palo Alto
Networks okay quite a few so our mission
is protecting the digital way of life of
our customers and I'm not explaining
exactly what we do with all the products
and features but what we call security
operating platform is a set of solutions
running on network as firewalls and
point cloud protection we're taught
firewalls running in the cloud and so on
that is meant to successfully prevent
cyber attacks that's what we do and one
of the reasons we have been so
successful and we grew so much is
because we allow our customers to
consume innovation and we allow our
customers to integrate our solutions
with their own solutions and with
third-party solutions that's very
important the automation and integration
for us is really a key part of our
success and one of the things we are
working on right now which is not
available yet but will be soon is
something that we call application
framework and again I don't want to get
into too many details you can come to
our booth
ask our questions to us but the point is
many of our customers have firewalls
running in their network are using our
endpoint protection solutions are using
our cloud protection solutions are
running virtual firewalls on GCP so for
the customers that want to do so we they
can actually send all the logs all the
data from these devices like security
locks security related data to our cloud
and by doing that they enable us to run
advanced analytics on top of that so we
have some solutions called white fire
magnifier and so on that can actually do
threat intelligence do user behavior
analytics on top of the data that our
devices and endpoint solutions put in
the data Lake and this has been working
for a while
so without framework we're adding
something more on top of that which is
providing third parties away so third
parties means partners other vendors
could be even competitors if they want
to do so and customers as well providing
api's to access the data that is present
in the application framework so as a
customer if you consent so you can give
access to your security data that was
gathered from Palo Alto Networks and is
stored in the Palo Alto Networks cloud
to a third party solution and through
api's these third party solutions can
integrate and do analytics do
remediation and do threat Intel there
are lots of use case and again vendors
and customers will be able to do this
and why we think this is important we
think that this is important because if
you look at the security consumption
model how many security vendors are out
there a lot and each single security
vendor provides some unique value to
customers the problem is that if you
want to try one of those vendors one of
those solutions or if you just want to
build a solution because you are a
vendor you want to build a solution does
analytics for example you will need to
deploy sensors deploy agents as a
customer and as a vendor you need to
write sensors write agents but your core
business is really analytics
or fret Intel you don't really need to
build that stuff but you need that in
order for your customers to consume your
unique value right and for customers is
painful to do these PLC's they're long
and complex the other problem is that if
you have lots of security solution you
have to deploy lots of things
infrastructure cost operations cost it's
hard to manage
and lastly integrating all these
different data sources and providing an
effective automation workflow that
protects the customer is hard so with
something like application of framework
we want to be the sensors and enforcer
in the network in the endpoint in the
cloud and allow again third parties and
customers to leverage our data to do
analytics so if you want to try a third
party solution you can just grant them
access to your data as a customer and
they're ready to go if you're a vendor
you want to build a solution that
integrates with that framework you don't
need to deploy and create sensors and
agents you just call our API so this is
very effective and you don't need to
reinvest reinvent the wheel every time
and the automation capabilities that we
can bring there are very interesting in
fact when we started working on this we
were thinking about some use cases and
the more we work with different partners
and different customers we learn
additional use cases that we didn't even
think about so that's really exciting
so this is what we are doing right now
and back to the security command center
integration point no sorry back to
slides
okay so what we did is building an
integration between the application
framework and the security command
center it's a simple application we'll
build it using serverless components we
use the Python SDK as well that was
pretty easy to do and that is that the
data is coming from traps our endpoint
solution from the fire was running in
TCP all this data is flowing in
application framework and from there
this security command center app is able
to pick the data up and generate
findings into security command center
and through some user interface you can
actually enrich those findings with GI
data you can act upon that data
providing blocking and remediation on
the firewalls potentially enable
third-party integrations on top of that
as well so this will become clear in a
second so what we are doing right now is
showing this flow so on the bottom you
have an endpoint which actually is the
Machine when I try to Bitcoin mine that
had a malware that was blocked by our
employment protection traps and the logs
are being sent from the endpoint to
application framework this will actually
be stored there and the Security Command
Center app that we wrote will pick up
this data detect that there is an alert
and create a funding insecurity command
center so we will see a finding there
hopefully and from there we will open
another console that we wrote again for
the purpose of this integration very
simple where we can do additional
analytics look at additional data and
enrich that alert with threat Intel
information that we have and eventually
block The Associated command and control
IP addresses on the firewalls so
protecting the other machines that are
running in the cloud and if for some
reason there is some machine that
actually has been infected by that
malware because maybe my colleague
wasn't that smart and he didn't
installed traps on it the firewall will
now block it and will tell us that
something is going on it was the
additional urgent security command
center
you can do so the question is can you do
the enrichment before creating the alert
yes you could
so the idea is we are doing that
manually so as a security analyst I
decide that I want to enrich the data
because I think that this is an
important alert that I want to enrich
but obviously you could change the world
flow now to make that and attract Intel
before creating the alert so let me go
to the demo okay thank you so this is
the dashboard there are two alerts now a
refresh and I see three alerts which
means that it's working which is
wonderful because this is an alpha
product from Google
it's a staging environment alpha for us
as well and our DevOps teams did some
deployment today so I'm lucky so if I
look at the details of the finding you
will see that we have some stuff in here
and one is called traps wildfire malware
so this specific finding was generated
you see on top eight minutes ago when it
actually tried to block - I mean I tried
to run the Bitcoin miner and that was
blocked by traps and I have lots of
information here the user that did this
francesco the IP address of the machine
that generated that the malware hash and
something interesting also is that this
is linked to the asset in Google Cloud
and this is important because traps
doesn't know anything about the fact
that that's an asset from Google Cloud
just knows the name P address and we
used actually the API provided by
security command center to ask in our
organization which machine had this IP
address at this point in time when this
event happened and their API said win
server one good so we added here so this
is the event as we see it and now I can
open the partner console which is again
simple application that we wrote right
now I'm pulling additional traffic and
threat logs related to that machine from
the application framework so I have pyro
logs and other stuff that they can pull
and visual
here and again I don't want to get into
too many details but one of the things I
can do is this is suspicious right so
let's see if Palo Alto network knows
something about threat Intel some threat
Intel about this a specific piece of
malware so when I click on auto focus
I'm calling again our cloud api's and
I'm pulling threat Intel information
from our cloud and if you see these
stats well I'm not getting into the
details or which one of that means but
basically it's telling me that this is a
specific piece of malware that is part
of a specific campaign and there are
some IP addresses and a few the ends
that are associated to this specific
piece of Malwa I will probably want to
block this before I do that let me
switch back to the security command
center console so by doing that we
actually added those auto focus tags
marks in the security event so this
means that even if I don't have access
to the other con so I just have access
to security command center the fact that
myself as an analyst did that enrichment
this information becomes available also
to my colleagues when they look at this
specific finding so back to our console
I want to block this I want to block the
Associated command-and-control IP
address so what I'm going to do is just
click in on block but before doing that
let me switch over to the firewall again
I don't want to get into the details on
how this works but this is our firewall
running in TCP I created a policy that
will block all the IP addresses that are
part of a specific dynamic address group
or dag and right now this group is empty
so there is nothing there if I go back
to my UI and click on block through
application framework we are telling the
firewall okay from now on you should
block the command-and-control IP address
associated to this malware so if I'm
lucky and get back here okay you see in
the firewall that IP address is now
being blocked and this information again
is also reflected in
here in security command center as an
additional mark so again as a fellow
analysts I can look into this and say
okay someone took care of this this
should be good enough so I can actually
do resolve here saying okay this
incident has been taken care of so I
just click resolved and if I go back to
Security Command Center this will now
disappear why because this would be
marked as resolved and I have a having a
filter here that is showing only the
alerts and the findings that are not
resolved so one last thing I want to
show you is that now that I actually set
the Block on the firewall I might want
to see if there are other again there is
other activity related to that specific
command and control for that malware and
actually there is so my colleague is
actually trying has a machine that is
actually trying to connect to that
command control and that was blocked now
and this is again something that I can
assume the firewall but also through the
integration with application framework
and this might take a few seconds to
show up because again the log is going
to application framework and the
application that we wrote is following
the data from application framework and
generating the finding security command
center so let's wait a few seconds if we
have them
I mean the last bit of the last demo of
the last presentation of the day
obviously there is some suspense right
here we go so see - traffic blocked
again this is another machine this alert
is still coming from application
framework but originally has been
created by the firewall not by the
endpoint agent but the user experience
is exactly the same and we have
different user and other information so
the previously incident has been
resolved but I have another incident I
should work on so that's all I had for
the demo let's go back to the slides one
more time please
thank you so takeaways first of all it
was fun and easy to integrate with
security command center
we had a great again Python libraries
were easy serverless was pretty good to
work with and Andy was great in
supporting us and the other takeaway is
that with application framework we
encourage vendors competitors customers
to come to us talk to us and build
applications that can leverage the data
we provide in order to provide value to
yourself so to your customers please
reach out to us because again you can
easily get access to the Palo Alto
Networks data if your customers allow
you to do so of course and with this
specific integration we were able to
build a simple single pane of glass
through security command center so
that's all I've got
inviting any back on stage for the
wrap-up
[Applause]
francesco so thank you so much I think
first I think first give a round of
applause to all the speakers who did
live demos we were four for four so a
little bit of bravery there I think to
quickly wrap up because I know work
towards the end of the day you know some
key questions that the Cloud Security
Command Center has helped answer for
customers around the assets a
fundamental question is what do I have
what am i running I think our experience
has been that with the shadow IT that
develops around cloud we actually
provide this visibility to customers
customers have sometimes been very
surprised the average amount our
customers are offer is about twenty five
percent some customers were off by a
factor of three who said how many assets
they were actually running in cloud so
that core visibility is one of the first
things they gain from this as we saw
with two Sigma CloudFlare and Palo Alto
the ability to integrate findings for a
lot of different places to get really at
things that are going wrong potential
risks and vulnerabilities in the cloud
it's now there been a huge win now in
addition with the own our own detectors
in cloud anomaly detection the security
scanning and the DLP it's given further
visibility to our customers as to what's
going on in their systems around the
finding pieces and as you can see from
the slide and going back to the original
slide about what we're building command
center to try to help you detect its
issues around your inventory around your
config around access around data and on
around the underlying applications
you're running in the public alpha
release that we announced there are
really five kind of key things that are
core of it and we've demoed most of the
things today the acid inventory pieces
today we support five of the Google
services in the acid inventory the
analysis the pieces that have been used
to allow you to find specific things the
marking part what we did in demo today
are the kind of the notification piece
that's built in to how you can use
command center to generate a pub/sub
through a sidecar application and also
to directly trigger actions through
cloud functions through a sidecar
application to create findings API that
each of the three our customers and two
partners have integrated with and really
again going back to that top goal
covering each of the five different
things we're looking for from a security
standpoint the ecosystem is you know
starting and continuously growing and
we're gonna add more this quarter into
the following quarters so and we're
hoping that you folks in the audience
whether you're a direct customer who's
writing findings wants your own
detectors or have specific partners that
you want to integrate you come talk to
us we can help prioritize that so to
learn more if we had a blog post back in
March all of our documentation is online
in public that includes the underlying
documentation as well as the API guides
and so with that I want to thank you
guys want to invite the other speakers
back up and I think we have a few
minutes for questions and but I also
recognize that we're keeping you from
drinks so I'm certainly cool if you guys
just want to like call it a day but
thank you guys
[Applause]
[Music]